definitely think the peace aspect is
great
it works
um
unconditional love and support
i'm like a really i realized
okay all right all right of course
there's gonna be boundaries okay of
course
there's boundaries it doesn't have to be
conditioned there's equal boundaries
when you respect someone and you're with
someone and you have an equal
right i kind of just want to wear it
like that i'm listening to their show
from last night so i was trying to like
think of answers if they have like
questions like that for me
um
okay so
basically
i can't i can't do the dressy thing i
just
it's not
i don't mind like
i just don't have a dress here that i
like really wanna wear so i think i'm
either gonna wear like
these shorts with the green top
these jeans with the green top
or
either or with hold on this inside out i
just dried it to get rid of the wrinkles
or either or with that one
so
this is outfit number one okay i'm gonna
come back in a second
okay outfit number two
and i think
this is probably what i'm gonna go with
um
[Music]
like i'm just not super comfortable like
super dressy clothes
or okay
or like
this one
okay
or okay
so
or
this one
no my hair is actually longer than
people think because mine's kind of wavy
but like when i straighten it it gets
pretty long
okay
thoughts
red so you said red orange
or okay one more
[Music]
now
uh
okay and then this is the other one
i kind of like it but it's a little too
like churchy i think
um
no i'm gonna do a reaction guys i just
don't know my equipment i'm traveling
so like i just haven't had time because
i'm going to a bachelorette party this
weekend
um
you go with the red top the jeans or the
shorts
okay
okay let's let's go back
messed up
so
so
okay
um
let's see the
and your dress
so it looks like you're about to sell
them real estate
it's definitely my mom's um red with the
black shorts
um
y'all i'm like jacked you don't even
know this i can eventually i can
deadlift like
i wish i could deadlift 300 to be honest
um
all right red top black shorts or jeans
okay so we're gonna
red top right
um
okay so option one
just wear a black dress i do have black
don't do this to me guys don't do this
to me
um
don't do this to me guys
but this is
i don't like the way my arms looking at
um
let's see
but i don't know i'm like so indecisive
that's what i love about literally like
the lives i do this on tick tock too
where i'll just have people like pick
out my outfits
no
no no okay
so we're thinking the orange top
probably that's probably what i'll do
yeah my problem is i'm like too cheap
i like never buy new clothes
[Music]
okay guys because i can't she's gone
again just like my dad guys i can't
change on camera
um okay
guys i know i know i don't i don't mind
like just wearing a normal outfit
you just try to look nice like
or hold on i have one more shirt
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god this is too tight
i'm not gonna do this
no
um
let's see
[Music]
what you guys
are you know i think i'm just gonna do a
tank top with jeans
oh my god
i'm the worst guys this is why girls
take so long to get ready i'm literally
the worst
but i don't want to wear jeans
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
i don't have a different bra though
[Music]
all right skirt with sleeves or shirt
with sleeves open up the front two
buttons
[Music]
shirts
[Music]
this is perfect
change nothing all right this is what
i think i've gotten the most positive
feedback from this maybe
okay i think this is actually my
favorite one
i'm like more of a
do i feel confident i never feel
confident especially in the mannequin
um
yeah the nanosphere actually
has humbled me
um
okay
[Music]
am i nervous i'm not nervous about
meeting them i'm just nervous about
saying something embarrassing because i
say embarrassing stuff all the time like
literally all the time
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh actually
i like this better
[Music]
okay
[Music]
oh
no acne lose 10 pounds and be a happier
person jesus
um
the shirt looks too big
[Music]
yeah i think so too actually
i think i'm gonna go with the orange
guys
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
yeah okay this is it this is it
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i don't like super tight clothes and i
don't like wearing like super revealing
clothes
like
i do occasionally but usually i'm a
little buzzed
because i do not like
[Music]
okay
i gotta leave
shouldn't your boyfriend guys i don't
have a boyfriend anymore
[Music]
it's just a casual no i know guys i'm
not like that nervous i just i'm more
nervous because i'm not like physically
where i was hoping to be before like
being put on full camera i've lost like
eight pounds but i was hoping to lose a
little more
um
no i don't want to drink
honestly
i drank this past weekend and i just i
don't like to drink about
drink like too much to be honest like
too often like i really only have like
once maybe twice a month
[Music]
i'm gonna brush my teeth
because i was eight
so
so what time is it i gotta get going
about five six
so
okay it's not too bad god damn
um
okay i'm gonna start
doing my vlog so you guys are gonna see
me live doing a vlog for
the youtube channel
okay
gotta turn off
all right
what is that
okay
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
on freshman fit and i am going to be
vlogging my experience so
first of all i'm gonna show you guys my
outfit took me like 20 years to pick out
because i'm very indecisive and if
you're live right now
right there you are going to see like
all the different outfits i went through
which is million
[Music]
but um
this is what we got going
it's a little mommy but that's kind of
my style it's like mom's material
[Music]
um
refrain from saying i feel like gosh
that's so hard
um
[Applause]
all right
all right
uh
i'm gonna bring you guys
with me
until it's inconvenient
say i think instead of i feel like
road trip
yeah it's like i'm like two hours away
from russian fit so i'm gonna stay in
miami tonight
um
just because
i don't know like i don't want to drink
it's like late the show
i'll plug you guys in
okay well this flip
orientation is locked
okay can this flip now
oh damn okay
i just plugged you guys in let me see if
i can balance it
okay so now i'm gonna pack
the [ __ ] i need oh i forgot i have one
of these
okay
um
have i been on the kevin samuel show
yeah like for a second
not super long
okay so i'm gonna pack
clothes or
clothes to sleep in
luckily i have two iphones
so
because i got the second one it does
it's not like connected to service or
anything but
it's for um
like recording stuff
[Music]
um so this
okay guys which shoes blacker
which ones
okay
i kind of want to work out in the
mornings
okay
got these
would you guys say black or tan black
okay black is
how tall am i um
six foot i'm tall as [ __ ]
pull up
okay
um
don't move to the you guys i get it i
got a sports opportunity
so
what's new
oh
i actually haven't weighed myself in a
second because
um i've been on vacation
and i keep thinking the next house is
gonna have a scale and it keeps not
okay
[Music]
okay packing that
um
i don't think i need to bring my nice
camera i can just probably film on my
phone
um
okay
hmm
[Music]
don't forget to email you about what
okay we're gonna take these chargers
and then i gotta figure out a hotel for
tonight
okay
i can probably just call someone on the
way
i'm surprised there's this many people
watching me do this live i'm like not
even doing anything anymore
um
okay
pouring this this
okay
oh no
okay
see now we are going to be
remote work lifestyle
true okay i'm packing my bag
i'm packing my car
oh cool there's outlets in here
gonna throw that in there
okay pack that bag
and i'm probably gonna do a little
i'll show you guys
so the cool thing about having two
phones and this is actually one of the
reasons i got two phones
regardless of what you guys want to
think i can be live
and show you and like do a vlog at the
same time so like i just use my phone
for a vlog so i'll just go like
all right guys so
i'm packed up i'll show you i just
packed it by
my bag the car's packed
i'm ready to go to miami
it's gonna it's gonna be a fun night so
i'm gonna keep you guys posted
and then
after party at pearls hotel guys you i'm
pretty cheap so you won't
you will not catch me
um
spending good money on a hotel
am i an introvert no that's why i talk
so much
i think i talked too much it's actually
gotten me in trouble
[Music]
you
[Music]
my blog is going to be posted on um
my youtube channel eventually
as long as i have i think i have
everything i need
um
okay
think of a question maybe i'll put on my
instagram story
but
questions but it's kind of like they run
the show so it's not like i'm going to
be the one asking questions
i'll be back tomorrow chaz
don't miss me too much
stop crying okay i'm going to be back
soon
they love me they just don't know it
the benefit i told you the benefit of
two phones guys i can do it live and
vlog at the same time
and um
i can do two live so if i want to go
live on tick tock i can go
um
you're gonna wear makeup what the [ __ ] i
am
no i couldn't find anything i liked
it was new okay guys
i'm